We have the opportunity to develop the same kind of user interface
to test this theory with three-dimensional models that can display all kinds of objects
whether they are molecules, threads, but also readers
with a simple implementation which might seem unreal for  all those who are used to building user interfaces.
My name is Guillaume Santini. I am a lecturer in computer sciences at the Université Paris 13.
I am a biophysicist
I did a PhD in molecular modeling
and I participated in the development of new theoretical models of the folding of the nucleic acids DNA and RNA molecules.
My name is Jean Cognet. I am a professor at the University Pierre et Marie Curie at Paris 6.
I teach biostatistics, biophysics of macromolecules DNA and NRA
and modeling, particularly with Mathematica.
Our team is working on the modeling of biological macromolecules.
This is to determine the atomic conformation of large molecules
that's why I bring you a little bit, so it's a small piece of a small DNA fragment.
So we had to write modeling software
This is something very complicated and heavy.
Classical modeling software allows us to represent these types of molecules,
[but] the concept of elastic thread is absent,
and they do not allow us to represent that thread. However, we need this tool in our research
So there are several aspects that seem interesting to me in Mathematica.
First from an IT perspective, we have different ways of programming in Mathematica
That is to say, it is quite well suitable to program with a mandatory approach
in languages such as C or PASCAL
it is also suitable for other programming approaches, such as the functional programming or approaches that are based on rewriting
The second advantage I see in it is the structure of the notebook
that allows us to detail our ideas, to write them, and to eventually test them.
That is to say to program, obtain the results, and analyze them in the same environment.
So there is this aspect of an integrated environment, where we can think
write, program, show results,
I would say that is conducive to effective development
And here I would say that thanks to Workbench
we finally have an effective tool to help develop the package,
and even more effective than the tools developed in the Workbench
we can now integrate all the documentation that we developed for our own account and for third-party users.
So from that point of view then we have tools that ultimately allow us
to integrate packages we develop directly into the architecture of Mathematica
and take advantage of all the flexibility and queries implemented in Mathematica.